j-dub from twitter says and what age did
you stop comparing yourself to your
mentors and heroes in order for you to
be happy with who you are
do you ever stop I don't ever stop yeah
no it's a comparison is is really
frustrating and I do and I haven't
stopped but I'm I'm definitely like
shedding that as I get older that's what
happens in the 40s that I again I did
never subscribe to the idea that the 20s
had a certain thing and the 30s had a
certain thing in the 40s but at least
for me the 40s have really led to I
really am carrying less and less about
other people and that I'm really only
striving to better something than what I
did already
do you know I mean I want my next record
to be better because I want it to be
better than the last record I made as
opposed to I wanted to be better because
this is success those people do that so
it's a it's that forever it I think it's
always gonna be there I mean for me it's
how I deal with those feelings of
comparison so instead of like you know
envying someone's picture on the beach
in Australia or something like I might
say to myself oh that's cool I hope one
day I can be able to do that but like I
don't let that pull me in a different
direction then I was already heading and
I think that's where the comparisons
really yeah start to mess people up
there's like you're heading I'm going
this way I'm going this way and then you
like you look over and like oh no no I'm
going this one I'm going this way and
then you look and then it's you can
never actually choose a direction
because you're constantly comparing
yourself to others I think comparisons
are important because in a sense like it
gives you something to shoot for you
know the person going through the
airport who is just like life is just
pinging off of them and they're enjoying
every single moment taking it all in and
all the bad stuff is just you know being
deflected like yeah that's a fantasy but
I mean it's not it's not horrible to
like shoot for that it's not horrible
also only coming from you right oh it's
the same thing of like when you're
driving in traffic and you're pissed at
somebody because you think they're an
idiot that's coming from you it's the
same thing it's like that person is a
mirror for the thing that you it's just
like what your partner is they give you
a reflection back of what it is that you
actually want so when you see someone
you project on them this experience you
say to yourself well
that person doesn't actually matter in
this situation what matters is like
apparently I want any use of use in my
life that I have not given myself how do
I go about getting that I want to not
sweat my way through the [ __ ] Airport
so like that it's feels like and that's
big and that's what's so great about
other humans but what also makes them
inconsequential because that woman could
have been anyone right you don't I mean
it's like it's me I'm telling my story
and I'm using people as a as a as either
to hate myself love myself or grow and
it's like well do what when you start to
compare yourself you can ask that deeper
question of like why am i comparing
myself what is it about this person that
I want what do I want that and when he
said why it's so important to because we
often think like before we turned all
the mics on stuff we were talking about
like doing shows that Bogart's and it's
like right I was like I was as concert
yeah Sabo guards was Everlast opening up
for Sugar Ray which I went there to see
Everlast and had no idea that Sugar Ray
is actually a freaking awesome performer
like you do Rath is one of the best did
an amazing show I was like oh like this
is why Everlast is opening up for you I
mean but anyway it's like you know
watching watching that that concert and
thinking like maybe one day I'll be up
on the Bogart stage and then you were
and follow everything that could have
went wrong went wrong right sentiment
was still there though I was still able
to appreciate like I am here Bogart
stage you you had the opportunity to to
be grateful for but I think there's a
sort of date on between what the two of
you were talking about you're so Ryan
you're saying you know sometimes
comparison can be good because it gives
you something to shoot for and what Matt
is saying is comparison could be toxic
because it makes you so it turns you
into this pinball that's just like well
if I'll do what this person says no
being up do what this person says Bing
and then all of a sudden you become
directionless in a way and I think I
think we're the two converge here is
maybe what Matt is saying is like well I
really am comparing myself to my future
self in a way a way to live your life as
opposed to constantly like gazing in in
the rearview and saying everything
screwed up back there well like yeah
it's okay to look behind you
occasionally boom
live in the rearview then we're certain
to crash there is something profound
about like the person that I compare
myself with the most is my future self
like that's good man yeah yeah and the
end the idea that I'm comparison to
other people you have such a limited
understanding of the other person that
you're actually you don't actually know
them so you're not actually comparing
them to because you don't know them you
don't even have any understanding
comparing a moment of their life you are
you are comparing your moment of your
life because you don't even know they
might be so uncomfortable in those
flowing clothes they might have a
[ __ ] the shingles underneath there
and they might be so uncomfortable and
they just don't show it on their face
there's the mirror windows outside yeah
so we're at this we work building here
and I mean the mirrors that like when I
walk by I always suck in and look at
myself walk anyway but I'll just work
down there sometimes like I'm on my
computer I see people walk up and it's
it's one of those sort of one-way mirror
so I see them and it's always the most
beautiful people who are scrutinizing
themselves the most and so like I see
the people in the mirror and then like
you don't need to look in the mirror you
are dressed perfectly but there's
there's and security there and then I
see the guy who's 70 pounds overweight
with the gut hanging out over his cargo
shorts and he just goes strolling by
because it's like and and you're like
the person who looks perfect should be
have the confidence of the guy who's
just strolling by so and to add another
level to this not to go but like I'm
somebody who looks pulled together in a
way that's appealing to us right that's
work and so of course they're gonna walk
by and they're gonna they're gonna
survey their work they focused on that
right so they're gonna walk by look and
be like hey how did I do and what else
can I fix here is this job you know just
like we would if I'm a songwriter and I
want to or whatever and so the all it is
is that they've put the emphasis on that
as something that's important to them
and that's one of the reasons they look
so good right is one of the reasons that
they look so good is that they focus on
looking good that's the priority and so
so of course they're going to be the
ones that look in the mirror because
they're checking they're probably how
are we doing this is
I got this I got cuz that and that's why
they looked that way I used to think
people just magically woke up and looked
amazing and then social media has taught
me that like beautiful people work real
hard at being beautiful right you know
if you're not paying attention it has
taught you that beautiful people just
wake up this one of course I mean how
the delusion of waking up next to
somebody in perfect white sheets with
the light coming through in Los Angeles
and they're like hair gets pulled up and
it's like whatever your thing is it's
like it meant that you can find that and
you can think I don't have that why
don't I have that cuz at my house I got
a [ __ ] wash the sheets every week at
my house I have cat hair on everything
Jimmy and then I start to think to
myself goddamn I don't have the thing
where we wake up and we pull the sheets
off and then we and we get in at
breakfast and the plate looks a certain
way and this and it's like yeah you know
what I don't want to do that actually
I just want to love that the plate I
have and the cat that [ __ ] on my rug and
I'm gonna live my life here and and and
I'm gonna find that here
you